once at each other's side now a hangover
from brexit causing fresh political
tension Boris Johnson pouring scorn on
attempts to change parts of the deal he
signed with the EU
the former prime minister throwing his
weight around with sources saying he
believes Rishi sunak needs to keep
controversial laws that would allow the
UK to rip up parts of the EU agreement
that legislation is currently paused in
Parliament this cabinet minister trying
to play Down the intervention Boris is
is being Boris but I wouldn't say this
is this is a completely unhelpful uh
intervention having the Northern Ireland
protocol Bill there having the work uh
that the former prime minister did is
has helped us get where we are but it's
always been our preference to try and
have a negotiated settlement meeting
European leaders this weekend Rishi
sunak has struck a friendly atone with
the EU with number 10 saying there'll be
no need for the UK to make changes on
its own if an agreement can be reached
with Brussels
but this senior labor figure predicts
more Tory infighting there's nothing
that Boris Johnson is doing now or
indeed throughout our recent history
with the European Union that could
possibly be described as helpful he's
wrecking he's trying to wreck the thing
so it's just a sort of continuation of
the fratricidal war that we see in the
conservative party
and that's something they could do
without here as Rishi sunak tries to
finalize an agreement with the EU over
Northern Ireland and find a fix that's
eluded his predecessors interventions
from Boris Johnson on this matter
because they have the potential to spark
a rebellion among Tory MPS that still
support him but in a way talk of another
brexit civil war here is something of a
sideshow because the people the Prime
Minister really needs to convince are in
Northern Ireland
the dup are currently blocking the
formation of the devolved government and
assembly in Belfast until they get
concessions in the brexit deal that
allow Northern Ireland to be treated in
the same way as the rest of the UK and
if you listen carefully to brexiteers
like this one support from the dup May
well mean support from the Tory party
too I think the dup has set out the
right test as to whether a new agreement
is in line with the Good Friday Belfast
agreement which is a fundamental
importance because that's what's given
peace to Northern Ireland for the last
25 years
it's been a weekend of diplomacy for
ishi sunak but number 10 is playing down
the chances of an imminent breakthrough
no easy wins it seems but this is a
prime minister badly in need of some
good news